we've got a big show today but I did
want to get one sort of quick story in
before we get to a bunch of other stuff
that we've got planned for you today we
have learned that a judge who sentenced
fracking protesters to outrageously
harsh sentences actually has family ties
to oil and gas firms just a coincidence
of course this is in the UK I'm talking
about Judge Robert althom who jailed
three fracking protesters at a Cuadrilla
site the first environmental activists
known to be put in prison for public
nuisance since 1932 with sentences of
around 15 months each it has now been
revealed that the judges family is
connected to oil and gas listen to this
the author family has a business which
supplies the Irish Sea oil and gas
industry his family is part of the
supply chain for the huge energy company
Centrica which has invested tens of
millions of dollars in fracking and the
judges sister previously wrote an open
letter in favor of fracking saying that
it would create jobs that same sister of
the judge and the judges parents run the
company supplying the fracking industry
called the JC althom & Sons and one
interesting question that has come up in
all of this and in thinking about the
fairness of this of these sentences is
the question of were these peaceful
protests they certainly weren't violent
but the protesters did end up in
addition to just demonstrating climbing
on the roofs of trucks that were taking
drilling equipment to the fracking site
they refuse to come down from the roofs
of those trucks for somewhere between 45
and 84 hours so it's not violent but
there are critics saying you know if you
get on top of company vehicles make it
so that they can't move it may not be
violent but it's sort of over the line
from peaceful I don't really know
exactly where the line is between a
peaceful and a violent protest
definitely this is not violence and
there's actually a law in the UK around
judges making these sorts of personally
impartial decisions which says that a
judge's impartiality can be questioned
if family members are politically active
or have financial interest in the
outcome of a case it seems like both
apply here the judges sister writing an
open letter in favor of fracking is
political activity having a business
that supplies the oil and gas industry
in the context of fracking is a
financial interest and so now as a
result the lawyers for the protesters
are trying to get the sentence is
totally overturned if they succeed the
protesters could be set free within
weeks
and this is we've talked about this in
the United States it's also happening in
the UK it has to be taken way more
seriously than it is so the micro
question is do you overturn a particular
sentence and then you've got to look at
here's what the sentence was here's what
sentences tend to be for this type of
crime here are the conflicts of interest
that we can identify with the judge in
question that's the micro question the
macro question is if you determine that
a judge has personal connections to a
case and that those personal connections
may have influenced something like
sentencing which can literally ruin
someone's life right the difference
between one sentence and another for a
particular action or crime can determine
the future fate of someone's life
shouldn't the judge maybe be removed
right like that the judges are supposed
to be neutral sort of unbiased
interpreters of the law period they're
not supposed to bring their personal
views or circumstances to the sentences
that they apply if you steal five grand
your punishment in total could end up
being well more than five thousand
dollars right between the restitution of
the money you stole legal fees court
fines lost wages prison time and the
time that you're not gonna be able to
work whatever the idea that if a judge
gives a bogus sentence because they were
impartial and and biased they were
partial and biased rather the idea that
the only repercussion is you cancel the
sentence and then nothing happens to the
judge that's ridiculous that is
absolutely ridiculous and we really need
to be taking seriously this idea that if
indeed judges are doing this it cat it
to be more than just hoops let the
people out of prison and otherwise let
the judge continue as before there has
to be more done and I'm not sure how you
do it because of the legal
infrastructure at least in the United
States around the impeachment
sanctioning and removal of judges send
me your thoughts I want to hear from you
about this I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
the show is on twitter at david pakman
show big program today it's maybe one of
the best Friday shows in at least a week
today's program sponsored in part by
Blink is comm slash Pakman I've talked
about blinkers before it's this awesome
app that I've been using for several
months now and what it does is take the
best and most critically acclaimed
non-fiction books and condenses them
into 15-minute audiobooks that you can
listen to in one sitting you could
listen to ten books in an afternoon I
know that many in our audience want to
expand their horizons and learn more
about all sorts of different topics but
we're mostly limited by time to some
degree I know I'm not able to read all
of the books that I want simply because
I've got other stuff going on and that's
why blink is - such a great tool you can
absorb the most important information
and insights from the book in one
sitting and our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink accom
slash Pakman if you're watching on
youtube click the link in the video
description and after that free trial if
you like blinka stand i think you are
going to like it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month go to be li NK is t.com
slash PA k ma n